hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2016 american fantasy and adventure
movie called fantastic beasts and where
to find them
the movie begins in 1926 when a dark
wizard named grindelwald is threatening
the magical community in europe risking
a war with humankind or so-called no
major since then all wizards and witches
from all around the world including
hogwarts have increased their security
and alert the scene moves to a british
man named newt scamander who always
brings a magical briefcase full of
fantastic beasts with him is embarking
from london to new york city
upon arrival he manages to pass the
security check by switching the
briefcases mode so that it looks like a
normal briefcase
meanwhile in new york authorities are
inspecting a building that has been torn
through
a witness claims that the building was
destroyed by a dark mysterious creature
that has a shape like a moving wind
not long after the building's wall
starts cracking and an unseen force
charges underground fissuring part of
the streets
back to newt he explores new york and
comes across a lady mary lou and other
second salemer supporters who are
spreading hate news about magic and how
wizards and witches could be a threat to
humankind
factory worker jacob kovalsky tries to
walk through the crowd and accidentally
kicks newt's briefcase
this action catches the lady's attention
while talking with her newt notices that
a fantastic beast called niffler has
escaped from the briefcase he
immediately chases after the creature
into the bank but eventually loses sight
of it
he then meets jacob again and eventually
drops an egg before leaving him
niffler keeps stealing jewelry and coins
from the bank visitors while newt keeps
searching for it turns out that jacob is
trying to get a loan to open up a bakery
but gets rejected as he cannot propose
anything as collateral
newt spots niffler entering a lift but
suddenly jacob shouts at him telling him
that the egg he is holding his hatching
newt panics and teleports them to some
place inside the bank
the confused jacob has no choice but to
follow newt to the underground bunker
after opening the vault with his magic
wand newt finally captures niffler but
suddenly the bank guards come to the
vault forcing newt to flee with the
teleportation the wizard prepares to
obliviate jacob which will erase his
memories but he hits newt with a
briefcase and runs away
afterward newt is confronted by tina a
witch who has been observing nude in the
bank and also works for the magical
congress of the united states of america
or macusa
she arrests him for using magic in front
of humans or no major and brings him to
macusa headquarters at the same time
macusa president serafina pickery and
the others are concerned about the
attack earlier afraid that it could lead
to a war between them and no major tina
and newt arrive at the room but the
president is not happy with her presence
as she is no longer working for macusa
as an auror or a dark wizard catcher
tina then takes newt to her old office
where they are confronted by graves when
he demands to see the briefcase they
find that it is jacob's briefcase which
is full of pastries
jacob returns home and accidentally
opens newt's briefcase releasing several
fantastic beasts newt and tina are
walking around the city when newt
discovers jacob's room which is
partially destroyed and finds jacob
unconscious
turns out that he was bitten by a
mertlap
he then repairs the building with magic
after that the pair take jacob away from
the apartment while throwing one of the
escape creatures back to the briefcase
on the other hand mary lou turns out
operating an orphanage while spreading
hate about magic to the children
she then brings several children
including emotionally damaged boy
credence to meet senator henry shaw and
his father the leader of a leading
newspaper company but they are dismissed
while being insulted as a freak
tina takes jacob and newt to her house
as soon as they arrive jacob is
immediately smitten with tina's sister
queenie who is able to read people's
minds
meanwhile cretan secretly meets graves
who orders him to locate a child with
immense power he foresaw and promises
him that he will teach him magic if he
fulfills the mission
after having a sweet dinner together
jacob and newt are given a room to stay
overnight
that evening newt gets inside his
magical briefcase and asks jacob to join
him
he treats jacob's wound with magical
herbs and introduces a thunderbird named
frank to jacob
he reveals that the real reason he came
to america is to bring frank home to
arizona he then shows the human the
entire landscape inside the briefcase
which is dwelled by various fantastic
beasts one of them is okami a creature
that hatched from the egg earlier while
jacob attempts to feed the creatures by
himself he comes across a snowy room
where he spots a dark entity called
obscurus encased in a bubble
newt warns him to stay away from it as
it is a very dangerous entity
jacob then agrees to help newt
retrieving the missing creatures as he
is the one who knows well about new york
places while walking across the street
they coincidentally find niffler who is
trying to pose as a sculpture inside a
jewelry store
newt chases after the creature
throughout the store which ends up
destroying the whole store
he finally is able to capture niffler
when it tries to run away the cops
arrive but they are distracted by a lion
walking in the street so they use this
opportunity to teleport away they spot
another missing creature a rumpant
wandering around the city in nude
attempts to lure it with strange and
silly movement
however the beast sees jacob and goes
after him
luckily newt manages to pull it back
into the briefcase just before it
strikes jacob with its enormous body
tina who realizes the boys are missing
silently follows them and takes the
briefcase with her when she has the
chance on the other side a formal
meeting is held for senator henry shaw
to promote himself in the next u.s
presidential election when suddenly an
unseen dark force appears wreaking havoc
the entire room before grabbing henry
and slamming it to the ground killing
him instantly henry's brother langdon is
aware that this is witchcraft tina
brings the briefcase to makusa
headquarters where suddenly jacob and
newt emerge from the briefcase newt
realizes that henry was killed by an
obscurial but no one believes him
graves then impound the briefcase and as
three of them arrested while locked up
newt and tina explained that an obscurus
is an uncontrollable aggressive dark
force developed in a young wizard or
witch whose magic is suppressed or
called obscurial
newt adds that an obscurial can't
survive past the age of 10. a few
moments later graves discovers an
obscurus inside the briefcase
because of that newt is sentenced to
death alongside tina who is accused of
helping him
newt and tina are brought into a room
where a witch extracts tina's memories
to lure her into the death pool
one of the memories is tina attacking
mary lou and comforting credence
newt manages to free himself with the
help of a creature and eliminates the
witches in the room
he eventually rescues tina and escapes
from the room meanwhile queenie senses
something wrong is happening thus he
releases jacob
both of them then sneak into a room and
retrieve newt's briefcase the four
reunite and queenie suggests tina newt
and jacob get into the briefcase
afterward she sneaks them out from the
headquarters with confidence credence
who is freaked out meets up again with
graves he urges him to continue locating
the obscurial also saying that he will
be honored among wizards forever after
the mission is completed meanwhile in
the orphanage credence finds a toy wand
inside modesty's bedroom
mary lou suddenly confronts them
thinking that the wand belongs to
credence and breaking it in front of
them
realizing that his adoptive mother is
going to beat him up again credence
becomes unstable and starts attacking
her ruthlessly with the dark force
since the last missing creature a
demiguise is invisible tina brings newt
to a speakeasy to meet narlock hoping
that he can give some information
however the goblin demands something to
trade and he wants a hand-sized
bowtruckle named pickett resting in
newt's jacket pocket
newt initially refuses and attempts to
offer other things but gets rejected
he then reluctantly hands over the
bowtruckle to him and narlock informs
him to check out a department store
suddenly horrors of macusa arrives at
the bar
turns out narlock silently tipped them
off
the situation becomes chaotic and newt
uses this opportunity to retrieve picket
and the group escape from the speakeasy
they head over to the department store
and find demiguise who is babysitting
another creature
turns out that newt is miscounted and an
ocumee shows up from the ceiling
since occamies adjust their body size to
fill up the available space newt orders
jacob and tina to find an insect to lure
him into a teapot
after the creature causes some trouble
into the store jacob eventually grabs a
cockroach and tosses it into the teapot
the ocumee sees that and immediately
shrinks as it charges into the teapot
all missing beasts are now retrieved and
newt invites the others to have a look
into the briefcase graves arrives at the
orphanage and finds the terrified
cretans
he concludes the kid he has been
searching for his modesty
upon arrival at cretan's abandoned
family home graves betrays credence
saying he is unteachable and useless
just after graves finds modesty the
boy's rage intensifies and is
disappointed with a man
he suddenly transforms and flies away
from there leaving a trail of
destruction behind him
newt spots the obscurial and goes after
him as he doesn't want to let makusa
kill him
he reveals credence is the strongest
obscurial alive as he manages to live
until that age while tina distracts
graves newt follows the obscurial into
an underground tunnel when he attempts
to calm credence down the auroras notice
this and immediately head over to the
scene
as cretan slowly transforms into human
form again suddenly graves appears and
repeatedly attacks newt causing the boy
to return into the obscurial form
tina arrives at the tunnel and manages
to calm him down but the macusa
president and the aura show up firing
towards him ruthlessly and eventually
destroying him after that grave scolds
macusa for their outdated laws and
refuses to bow down to the rules any
longer the president then orders orris
to relieve graves of his wand but the
man fights back and attacks the oars
newt summons a fantastic beast and
subdues graves while tina takes his wand
from him
newt casts revellio on him revealing
graves real identity which turns out to
be grindelwald macusa then arrests him
since cretans has caused a huge damage
across the town newt has to summon frank
and uses it to take a memory wiping
potion into the sky turning it into rain
and obliviating the whole citizens
at the same time horrors also repair the
destroyed building with their magic
the president thanks newt for his
assistance but she reminds him to
obliviate jacob as well since there is
no exception
jacob says his final goodbye to his
friends in tears before stepping into
the rain and forgetting anything queenie
also gives him a warm goodbye kiss
since then everything goes back to
normal and jacob continues his life as a
factory worker
newt bumps into him anonymously and
drops a briefcase full of akumi eggs he
leaves a note telling him to offer the
eggs as collateral and pursue his dream
to open up his own bakery
not long after newt returns to london to
finish a manuscript titled fantastic
beast and where to find them
he says goodbye to tina and promises her
that he will send a copy of it to her at
the end of the movie jacob finally is
able to open his own bakery and shapes
his breads to look like some of the
fantastic beasts he vaguely remembers
queenie visits the shop and jacob smiles
a little when he sees her
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching